Hey everybody, it's Mike here and you
know, I'm going to make this quick video
because a bunch of people have been
asking me about my thoughts on this uh
suspicious-looking crude oil trades that
have been going on since uh basically
the start of the war in the Middle East.
And you know, the other night was a
great example
of
some very suspicious activity. Okay, now
I remember us first finding out about
this one on on Twitter
by a post by the Kebasi Letter uh when I
was just sort of going through my tweets
in the morning.
And according to her analysis, you know,
$920 million worth of crude oil shorts
were taken 70 minutes before an Axios
report claimed that the US and Iran were
near a deal.
At 3:40 a.m. Eastern time, again, this
is on May 6th, nearly 10,000 contracts
worth of crude oil shorts were taken
without any major news. This is
equivalent to about $920 million in
notional value, which is an unusually
large trade for about 3:40 a.m.
Okay, then obviously for at 4:50 a.m.,
but just 70 minutes later
the Axios report came out that the US is
close to a uh
MOU to end the Iran war. Okay. So,
they use a uh TradingView chart, you
know, it's light crude oil futures on
NYMEX, you know, and then they they sort
of show what
took place.
You can see the heavy volume when the
report came out, the big red bar down.
Um but prior to that, you see a couple
big red bars down on on heavier volumes.
Now,
this looks like about 5-minute chart
that they're using, possibly or even
10-minute chart. It's hard I can't
really tell.
But um
interesting they'd use light crude. They
probably should have used Brent crude,
which is something that tracks uh Iran
Iranian crude more, but you know,
nevertheless,
looking at the order flow. So, this is
when the big sell-off came in. And you
know, it was interesting because this
red line here is our low of the day, so
you're starting to see the sell-off
going into the low of the day. Now, this
low was made um sort of on the reopen
around 5:00 6:00 Chicago time.
5:00 or 6:00 p.m.
Um the evening before. Again, this is
2:40 in the morning.
Not a lot of liquidity in the market at
that time. Granted, it's again it's
early morning. Now,
you know, we were talking about stuff
happening in the Middle East, so
obviously that's going to be the US
morning time due to the time change.
And you can see the heavy volumes down
here, the 327 891 1320, right in here.
You know, so this is about uh
what 320 though?
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> 1,000 2,000 3,000 contracts within about
uh 3 minutes. Again, this is uh
June crude, okay?
So,
you know, there is some decent volumes
that went through.
And then obviously when we took out
these lows here,
the new lows, obviously again, more
heavy volume coming in, making new lows.
Now, it's not uncommon to see heavy
volume come in at new lows of the day.
Really, what we want to be looking for
is, you know, is there any suspicious
activities?
Well, I don't know. I mean, some of
these could have been stops that got
triggered. Or again, we're at we're at
the new lows of the day. We're trading
below, you know, 100 bucks. I mean,
we're already
we're there earlier after we reopened
the night, you know, at at 5:00 Chicago
time.
But again, you're talking about a time
where there's not necessarily a lot of
liquidity, and it it doesn't take much
to move the market, you know, we're
literally from this low here at 9912.
You know, all the way down to 9759.
Is there any big liquidity in there? You
know, here's 100 lots that went through
right here, 136. Resting liquidity is
what I'm looking for. You know, the
pretty much all most of these are just
resting liquidity.
Not a lot, you know, okay, but you know,
nevertheless, you know,
there is
you always got to be wondering, you
know, the conspiracy theorists and
everybody
is saying, you know, there there's
something happening.
Probably there's probably some
rumblings, but really what I like to
look for rather than, you know, I say,
"Oh, you got the big volume surge here,
something, you know, this is some
insider trading."
What about right before that big volume
surge, right? Because, you know,
is there anything that was sort of
peaking out?
You know, and
you know, if if you look at sort of the
volumes before,
you know, this is 1:00 a.m. sort of the
transfer of the book from Asia to to
Europe. Yeah, there's some you putting
this little swing low. Got some decent
volumes, some supportive buying coming
in, you know, around the 9987
area, the 63, you know, 2618, but after
that, then it really dries up
volume-wise. You know, you can just see
the volumes are very small, you know,
50 contracts and below for the most
part.
And looking at the volumes on the
footprint, again, very light, single
digits for the most part. You know,
here's an 14, here's an 11, here's a 12,
here's an 11, but everything else is
just twos and fives. Here's a 27, here's
a 10, here's a 12. Everything else is
just,
you know, and some prices don't even
trade anything, right? That's how
skittish this market is. You get this
little burst up here. This looks like a
buys big order that went through. Maybe
it was a buy stop, but it just sweeps
through the market and sits on the bid.
Some decent volume went through, 664,
as the market sort of spikes up.
Okay.
And then it's just sort of going
sideways, sideways, sideways, sideways,
sideways, sideways before it starts
getting a little bit weaker.
And we're putting in sort of these,
you know, this is our swing high, a
lower high, another lower high, another
lower higher lower high.
You know, then we got a lower low, lower
low, lower low.
So, it looks like, you know, price
action wise, you know, maybe this market
is starting to come off anyway.
Um
but what what I really what to me what
stood out
is this here. I'll just
highlight it. Um you know, just ahead of
the sell-off here, we got 59 contracts
on the offer.
Cuz I'm looking at the offer cuz this
market is starting to trend lower,
period. Right? Cuz we've got our swing
high, lower high, lower high, lower
high.
So, we got a lower high, lower low,
lower low, lower low.
Okay, so it's already coming it's just
doing one of these things.
Okay, so it's already trending down
anyway. Okay?
But again, sort of getting back here,
so I'm looking at the offer 27 cuz as
the market's going lower, I want to be
looking at what the volumes are doing on
the offer cuz that to me that signifies,
you know, a passive seller coming in
trying to distribute their position
in a downtrending market. Okay? And I'm
just circling all these volumes.
25 contracts and above.
Okay?
This one's 24, but you got what? You got
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 contracts. That's volume that's on
the offer.
Okay? You don't see any big bids coming
in at all. You know, here's a 13 here.
What do we got? We got a 12, a 10, and
11 here. Here's an 11. Here's an 11.
It's a
12 and 13. Here's a 10.
Here's an 11.
Here's a 14.
So,
comparing the volumes on the offer
compared to the volumes on the bid,
you can just see it's weighing heavier,
right? Because again,
this area,
basically here, we are going sideways
for the most part.
And as we're going sideways,
what we have, right? We're
consolidating. And what we have in that
period of consolidation is heavy offers
coming into the market.
Again, 25 is not
heavy, but it's heavy for this time of
day.
Okay?
And again, I'm comparing it to the
volumes on the bid side. And you know,
we barely see any bids. You know, here's
another 13 here. So, we got 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10.
We got 10
bids that were over 10 contracts, but we
got, you know, 13 or 14 offers
of 25 contracts or more.
Two and a half times the size of the
heaviest bid in a market that we're
going sideways. Where's the easiest
place to sell
if you're an institutional trader
in a market that's rising or in a market
that's going sideways?
Okay? So, we don't see a lot of
necessarily have a lot of buying
interest, passive buying interest,
people thinking, "Hey, this is a good
area where I could be buying." But what
we see is a lot of passive sellers,
selling interest. Again, could just be
one person or or a few. Most likely
somebody sell 25, sell 25. Okay, work on
another 25. Works on more work market's
going up. Yeah, sell another 25, sell
another 25. Right? And then it drops
down, it starts pop poking back up, sell
another 25, sell another 25. Okay? Right
before that big drop. I found that much
more interesting than that big volume.
Now,
you know, it sort of takes a little bit
of a trained eye to sort of pick that
up. But what to me what was the most
interesting is this right here.
And
I talk about this a lot.
This is one of my favorite setups. This
is the abandoned value area, the
abandoned prominent point of control.
And literally, in strategic traders the
other day
before this even happened
I had been talking about it. Here as you
know, what's one of my highest
confidence order flow setups is
literally this, the abandoned prominent
point of control
and the abandoned value area, which is
right here.
Right? This is it. It's the value area
that's not traded into in the next bar
and the point of control is not traded
into the next bar. Now, there's actually
other things in the order flow that's
interesting, right? We also have
point of control on the extreme on the
very high of the bar, right? We got an
imbalance reversal.
This is 27. We got a bearish ratio of
three
.3 rather. We got heavy stopping volume.
Okay?
So,
I'm not saying that, you know, this was
the sign of a 12 point or 12% sell-off,
but for
but I I
can safely say, you know what? You could
have
positioned yourself to catch most of
this move down from, you know, one, you
know, 100 spot 50
all the way down for, you know, at least
down to 99 50, a buck move, you know,
and obviously did go lower.
But, to me this was to me this was like,
mhm, the the French kiss of this whole
thing and it came in right before all
that suspicious activity came in.
You know, of what came out in that tweet
of
what was it here?
Right? Right here cuz this coming in
Where is it here?
Right? It's coming in
sort of right in this area in here
before you get this sell-off.
And that's just a pure order flow read.
Right? It's something that
we see
every day.
You know, even
we have this big move down. All right,
you see it in
in every market. All right, big move
down. Boom, boom, boom. You don't see
that set up. You don't see it again.
Did reappear. Where? Right here.
Hit these new lows.
Right in here.
All right? And you see the market sold
off
further down into new lows. Again,
you know, in a market like this, you
don't know how much lower it can go,
honestly.
But, you know, if you're getting short
somewhere in here, you know, what is
this?
50?
You know, where does your stop go? It
just goes on the other side, right up in
here. So, basically, I don't like this
color.
Um
you know, this is your risk
to capture this.
All right? Just as
you know, earlier,
you know, everyone wants to
know where to place your stop, right?
All you got to do
Right? Your stop just goes on the other
side up here. You're getting short
somewhere in here.
Right? Right in here.
This is your This is your risk here.
That's your reward.
Whichever one you want.
So, anyway, guys, you know, that that's
my thoughts on that suspicious activity.
Um,
you know, there there is another tweet
that came out today that
Department of Justice and uh CFTC is
going to investigate. You know, we know
how those things go.
Um
you know, but you know, the other side
note is
the market didn't rally later. There was
another report that came out, which was
bullish.
And so, after we
sold off 12% in crude oil,
the market rallied 8% after uh
Iran came out with uh some bullish news.
So,
you know, these markets are they're
crazy. And you think, you know, if
you're trading, obviously, you got to
use stops. You have to use stops.
And
you know, a market like crude,
is you're you're at the mercy of
you're at the mercy of the news cycle.
You know,
something could come out instantly, and
next thing you know, there is no
liquidity to get out, and you're
looking, you know, instead of getting
stopped out with some slippage of a just
a couple ticks, you could be looking
slippage of, you know, like this when
this this sold off. And everyone talks
thinks, "Oh, I'd have a stop here and
get out." No, realistically, you know,
honestly, if you had a stop, I mean, you
could just see these volumes. There's
there's nothing trading.
There's all these zeros in here on the
offer side.
Everyone, this is what's called, you
know,
cascading of stops is, you know, there's
there's stop stop stops.
They're all tripping over themselves,
competing for the same
bid. I mean, obviously, not competing
with themselves, but it's a queue
system, so you're just seeing it just
sort of cascade into the next one, into
the next one, into the next one. So,
even though you think, "Well, you know,
if I I'd have a stop, you know, for
whatever reason, if you were long here,
right, at the 9840s." So, I'll have a
stop at 40, and you You and then the
same would so you you you got out at 37.
You know, realistically, you probably
would have got out
you know, 98. You know, your stops at
40.
I would have been
filled somewhere around 98 bucks, 97.90.
But anyway, guys, um
it's just interesting
interesting thing to talk about. Um you
know, cuz again, a lot of people have
been asking my my thoughts on it.
But um
thanks for watching.